when I'm training speakers I tell them
the best speakers are the best listeners
to listen to things that touch your
heart the speakers often forget many of
the terms and concepts they live with a
completely unfamiliar to their audiences
when you want to make your point tell
stories
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world now I started to believe
life series to tackle different person
development topics on a weekly basis to
help you be the best version of you so
let's live our best believe life and
learn today how to become a better
public speaker joy
[Music]
let's start off with why it's important
with Warren Buffett one of the things
you would want to be sure to do is
whether you like it or not get very
comfortable that may take a while with
public speaking for example I mean that
that's a an asset that will last you 50
or 60 years and it's a liability if you
don't like doing it and are
uncomfortable doing it that also will
ask you 50 or 60 years and it's a
necessary skill
now to the rules number one study
yourself and others with Les Brown when
I first started out I disciplined myself
to learn about three quotes a day
somebody taped me one time I gave a
lecture at a manpower conference a
bishop TD jakes and they said I did over
215 quotes and I never repeated myself
so it's that I love quotes it's a
passion of mine and so they come up when
they come up at the appropriate time and
you have your own acquits I have my own
and I study a lot of other individuals
and once I hear it I repeat it to myself
and reuse it in conversation I when I'm
training speakers I tell them the best
speakers are the best listeners to
listen to things that touch your heart
and and then use it in conversation over
and over again and then use it onstage
when you're speaking to an audience yeah
not only you and your thought but also
the people who are everybody that's
around you great and do you advise to
people to write their own quote I think
that yes you want to write but sometimes
you are saying them and you can't hear
them because you can't see the picture
when you're in the frame and so when I
tell people if you're speaking to always
record yourself because they're things
is gonna come up inspiration revelations
you will receive you say whoa right
that's right yes and so you want to read
yeah that rule number two use silent and
vocal range properly with Charlie
huppert but for now let's continue with
how Neil uses silence to create tension
the most astounding fact is the
knowledge that the atoms that comprise
life on Earth the atoms that make up the
human body are traceable to the
crucibles so you're gonna notice two big
things here one the first thing is how
that silence gets you hanging because he
places it before completing his thoughts
and this gets you leaning forward in a
way saying go on go on it is fantastic
for capturing attention now I don't use
it a whole lot on YouTube because
clicking away here on YouTube is a lot
easier than
walking away from someone in real life
and attention spans here are very very
short but in your normal speech play
around with slowing your cadence down
and see if that gets people listening
more attentively the second thing here
is his range so let's listen again to
that last phrase are traceable to the
crucibles the crucibles has such a
breathy quality this is something you'll
start to see a lot for me he has
incredible vocal range now I don't just
mean that in terms of pitch but I mean
that in terms of style he shouts he
speeds up he emphasizes certain
syllables and he whispers in fact you'll
notice that when someone has your full
attention builds it up to a big point
and then whispers it drags you in even
more you can see in the next part how he
actually plays with these pauses and
sometimes he even rushes through the end
of a sentence he actually blows right by
periods as he does in this next part
when he says these stars that cooked
light elements into heavy elements in
their core under extreme temperatures
and pressures these stars the high mass
ones among them you see that he actually
shifts the speed and the rhythm he
doesn't always pause after his periods
and he doesn't always connect words
right next to one another sometimes he
has a giant pause in the middle of a
sentence that makes his speech much more
interesting rule number three use
metaphors with Chris Anderson three
build your idea
piece by piece out of concepts that your
audience already understands you use the
power of language to weave together
concepts that already exist in your
listeners minds but not your language
their language you start where they are
but speakers often forget many of the
terms and concepts they live with a
completely unfamiliar to their audiences
now metaphors can play a crucial role in
showing how the pieces fit together
because they reveal the desired shape of
the pattern based on an idea that the
listener already understands for example
when Jennifer Kahn wants to explain the
incredible new biotechnology called
CRISPR she said it's as if for the first
time you had a word processor to edit
DNA
CRISPR allows you to cut and paste
genetic information really easily now a
vivid explanation like that delivers a
satisfying aha moment as it snaps into
place in our minds it's important
therefore to test your talk on trusted
friends and find out which parts that
they get confused by rule number 4 pay
attention to your body language with
Thomas Frank pay attention to your body
language and this is important for two
specific reasons number one your body
language forms a large part of the
nonverbal communication that complements
the verbal communication of your words
the way you hold yourself the way your
poise your posture the way you move your
hands and gesture to highlight certain
points these all go hand-in-hand with
the words you're speaking and can help
to compliment and drive home those
points but the other reason is that the
unconscious body language that a lot of
inexperienced speakers have is something
that can harm you we have a lot of
nervous tics for example when I was an
inexperienced speaker just starting out
a lot of things that I would do I would
put my hands in my pockets and I guess
the cameras fixed right there but I can
try to show you right I put my hands in
and out of my pockets over and over
again while I was speaking and it would
also pace around the stage really
distractedly kind of moving and I wasn't
really consciously pacing and using that
to effect I was just doing it
unconsciously so these are things that
you can control to both not distract
your audience but also to help bolster
your points and rule number 5 the last
one before the bonus clip is tells
stories with Patrick be David sometime
when I get asked to speak for three
hours and they want to do Q&A that's a
different talk than it is from an hour
to just give a presentation than it is
from hey can you give a ten minute talk
here then a five minute talk if I'm
asked to talk five minutes on TV or on
whatever it is that I'm speaking for
five minutes
I'm here's a point here's a story Donna
let me tell you bout what's going on
over here here's the conditions that
we're looking at right now that's a data
here's what I think we need to consider
change into and here's what I believe
will be the solution and we tell you why
I believe this I remember was 1992 and
bomb story okay story so get into your
story when you want it to make your
point tell story somebody who is very
good at making stories
and figuring out ways for me to take a
metaphor or an analogy that I can excise
that makes that makes sense I get it I
got it I respond to that and most people
respond to that as well if you're
telling your story
now I've got a special bonus clip about
public speaking with myself and sage CEO
Stephen Kelly but before that the
question I have for you is have you
thought about being a public speaker and
what is holding you back from really
doing it or if you are doing it on a
bigger scale I'd love to hear from you
leave it down the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clip
John Holt is writing in asking about
becoming a public speaker wants to be a
speaker wants to find places to speak
and fail as a beginner but in places
that won't ruin his credibility in the
future when he's awesome so any what
advice you have about becoming a speaker
and failing at the start and finding
places to get some experience so you can
overcome those early adversities yeah
you kind of said it I think um in terms
of the question it's all about practice
you know it was some families go for
thanks Garry Blair who said kind of the
more I practice the luckier I am the
more you practice the better speaking of
it and I just think it's a gift but it's
a gift that can be taught and learned
and it's an area where you know we talk
about an industry before it's an area
where I start if you wanted to get into
it go into an area actually which is
sometimes the most difficult area people
when she know you sometimes you will
feel that it's easier to present to
complete strangers than people who know
you but actually if you work and start
presentations with people who know you
then it could be like at a new community
group or you go back to your school if
you've got a job where you're a startup
or a coder you go back to talk to the
computer science kind of high school
kids and do a presentation about why
should they be excited about what a
computer starts and coding and that's a
great way and then you can kind of go
along to the teachers to teach and say
having that Dean walk it out differently
but after then when you've done a
presentation then it's about there's a
magical workroom questions those friends
of yours like what could have done
better
what kind of done differently you know
and what messages till we found a resume
and then also kind of just always ask
feedback this feedback is absolutely the
food of a group so that's what I thought
test drive exactly what you say don't
worry about failure there is no failure
it's just practice I totally agree I
would also start a YouTube channel get
used to speaking in front of a camera
and having people see your opinions and
maybe it's a little less intimidating
than speaking in front of an audience at
the start I get a lot of or maybe most
of my speaking gigs through my youtube
channel people see me talking and they
want to hire me to speak it
vents and you talk about the question
talked about places the speak word
ruinous credibility in the future I
don't think there's that many places you
really have to worry about ruining your
credibility you know the first place I
spoke at was the YMCA and three people
showed up at my free event you know not
not the biggest start but does it look
bad on my resume that I started at the
YMCA you know I don't think there's that
many places that really would be a knock
against you that's where you started so
just started to all the Stephens one
speech out to your network places that
you've worked before teachers clubs that
you're a part of I just offered to do a
speech to get some practice and and also
get on YouTube film those speeches do
your own sessions just one on one with
the camera and the more practice you get
like Stephen said the better you're
gonna get it speaking raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that mm-hmm
that people need passion and not one
drop of most self-worth depends on your
that's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in the description for details